good afternoon
so i'm jacob kim and i'm the web master
at the hershey museum in sculpture
garden and i primarily work with
web and digital projects that interface
with on the public engagement side of
things
um dan michaelson is our
you know introduce yourself uh i i i'm
an
adjunct faculty in the graphic design
department at the school of art um
i teach a couple of the interaction
design classes to the grad students
there
um but i also run a digital studio
in new york city is my full-time job and
that's uh that's how i got connected
with uh with the hershorn
right and dan was our creative lead and
um
development lead on the hershon eye
project and
i'll talk a little bit about the steps
that we took
up to developing this digital engagement
product
and then then can go into a little bit
more detail
so the hershey museum is a smithsonian's
national museum of
modern and contemporary art and our use
case
for machine vision was to create
a digital engagement product to be used
in our galleries
um one of the benefits of being a
contemporary art museum is that
we have access to living artists
a lot of the artworks that we exhibit in
our galleries
the artists are still around today so we
wanted to take this
advantage and leverage in our way where
we can share their
stories and create more context for the
artworks that are being exhibited
at the hirschhorn
when we started exploring different
engagement products out there already in
existence
and technologies we were looking for
something that could help
kind of deliver that point of view from
the living artist
and we started looking at a wide variety
of different technologies and products
out in existence
to help facilitate this vision we looked
at technology such as vr
ar products in-gallery interactives
native apps and such all these tech
products had very strong merits of their
own
but they weren't exactly what we were
looking for a lot of them were
cumbersome they took a little bit of
foot space inside the museum galleries
and we wanted something that would be
a little bit more invisible
so with our market research we finally
arrived on a
vision for a product that we want to
develop on our own
and to help um
part of the vision for that uh product
that we want to develop was
to create a connection between the
visitor the living artist
and the artworks that are presented in
our galleries and to tell their stories
we started with an old model of
the traditional audio guides that are
available and we wanted to use
emerging technology technologies to
create kind of the next generation of
audio guided museum guide
for our space
and when we started that process we
started looking at technology such as
qr codes location-based technologies
beacons
but all that felt very uh cumbersome
and not very user friendly for our
visiting public
ultimately we settled on leveraging
image recognition
technology to create a product where
a user could go to a website point their
phone at artworks
and listen directly from the artist
talking about their practice
so in partnership with link by air and
antenna international we developed this
product called the
hershon eye the hershoni is a web-based
museum
guide it uses computer vision to
recognize the artworks in our galleries
and deliver content
and i'd like to show you a little video
about how it works
oops it just takes something to start
there we go
welcome to my artwork in the lobby of
the hershon
um so i thought i'd talk a little bit
about um
sort of the process that let this
project um
come together and maybe it's nice to
kind of um
and uh or conclude this amazing set of
talks with sort of some
uh snapshots in a way of of um
of a team trying to to apply
the kind of research that you guys are
doing and that everyone here is doing in
different ways
one thing that we sort of realized
early on is that thinking
cross-functionally and in an
interdisciplinary way
is really essential and so i'll sort of
start with the
with the thank yous rather than end with
them um you know the project was a
collaboration between
um you know actually a pretty wide group
of stakeholders within the hershorn
museum from the director to curators to
exhibition designers and jacob and
visitor
visitor experience people
as well as a cio on like technical
infrastructure issues that arose antenna
international which helped with
production a really great
team of filmmakers in new york called
captain in the fox
user testing specialist a marketer
the image recognition itself is like the
easy part in this project it's um
it's an api service from a company based
in
barcelona and you know sort of to
catherine's point um at this point the
actual image recognition at least in a
project like this
is a um a commodity basically we're a
small
um business and uh the
technical challenges per se were were
not large
for us we didn't need to be in amazon
and similarly my students in the art
school are doing
lots of stuff around computer vision and
image recognition now
so there are this kind of work is
definitely
um percolating into um sort of the
creative atmosphere for sure and i think
that that's really leading lots of
really interesting opportunities
our role was the user user experience of
the
product and really thinking that through
holistically the interface design what
is it what does it look like and how
does it actually work
on the screen and the engineering other
than the actual
image recognition
neural network itself um also really
involved were the artists who
um you saw olaf foreign starting to tell
a story about his work
but um the key to this was not
it's not it's not it's not interesting
to um
tell the user what is the title of the
work the purpose of this is to connect
the user to
an artist talking about the work and so
what stories they're telling
[Music]
is like 90 of the product and also
as i'll talk about we learned a lot from
what we would typically call users but a
museum would tend to call visitors um
the people who are actually um using
this product in this space
um you know so today rebecca really at
the very beginning of this morning
talked about
or sort of evoked like a large team and
kind of big science working together
and you know in a humanities product
project like this one
an interdisciplinary team is also really
important
especially for a project that
takes images in the physical environment
as its input and basically it's its
images and images out you get an other
you get other moving images as the
output you're transforming
um pixels into pixels so thinking
synthetically about user experience
technology visitors artists curation
what are the sequence of works that are
being
brought together content production
staff maintainers how was
how are people at the hershorn authoring
these stories and continuing to
expand and change them as new
exhibitions are mounted
and also how our visitor stat experience
staff on the floor
helping visitors use this
and also the physical environment which
i'll talk a lot about or talk more about
in a minute thinking synthetically and
holistically about all of that
even when those are the domains of
multiple different vendors multiple
different departments
multiple kinds of thinking is really
important for success
here's an early snapshot of a team
of hershorns and smithsonian staff and
also i think that's alice from antenna
brainstorming and testing and you know
lots of this project was
you know scanning simulations of images
in small offices and figuring what that
would be like
um i think this was sort of one of the
first um
web based applications of its of its
kind in in this space and
this is possible because that is the
case because um
uh as of 2017 when
um it was only with ios 11 was it
possible to
uh scan an image in real time in a web
browser
so ios 11 came out in like the fall of
2017
right around the time that this product
was meant to launch
so we were sort of developing towards a
thing that didn't yet
exist and there was a lot we really
didn't want to launch this as a native
app
um because we know from research that
the um the take up of
native apps in a museum like this is
really low people don't want to install
an app on their device that they're only
going to use once um or not
often
so that involved this sort of embrace of
risk a little bit on everybody's part to
think about you know developing for
something that hopefully was going to
work
six months down the road and we
managed that by having sort of fall back
since uh we had a sort of native app
fallback that we could use if necessary
um
peter talked about uh or mentioned how
to work
with rather than against human curation
and expert description and and i think
that was really
sort of key to our thinking that um
you know it's not the technology that's
the end but the technology is just an
instrument for
storytelling and for connecting users to
living artists telling their stories
[Music]
user testing was a huge part of our
project and and
and we did that with uh with hershorn
staff we did it with
um smithsonian staff at one point like
hundreds of smithsonian staff
um we did it occasionally with random
music random visitors on the floor
and very importantly we did it by
recruiting
testers on facebook and places like that
in order to ensure that
we had a diverse had diverse
demographics among our testers
um a big goal of the
project was to show
diverse artists actually from
of all genders nationalities ethnicities
and um and similarly a goal
was to make contemporary art which can
be alienating and intimidating
feel accessible to lots of different
kinds of visitors meaning like tourists
off the
mall who were not art experts and also
people of all ages and cultural
backgrounds
so testing with lots of different kinds
of visitors
was essential and we learned so much
from doing that and i'll talk about
some of the a couple i'll give a couple
examples of what we learned
um testing at the hershorn goes outside
as well it is also a sculpture garden
here are non-staff testers
and even seeing how people sort of
physically bodily use these products
use this use this product or how they
how how do they stand
how much are they looking at artwork how
much are they looking at their phone
is really helpful both sort of
quantitatively like sometimes it's
something we needed to address or
remediate like when people were sort of
not using the thing in a way that's
going to
work or would interfere with their
enjoyment but also
qualitatively just understanding that
different people are going to use
this interface in different ways um
um one thing we learned pretty quickly
not so much from user testing but from
looking at sort of other
similar applications is that um
no one lots of people will be confused
and think that you can use this website
when you're not at the horn museum
and um so we thought should we use you
know location permission
um and you know but that can be kind of
intrusive
and i think in the team finally kind of
collaboratively came up with this
really basic this is the dumbest thing
you've seen all day um
we'll just ask people and that's
actually been i think a really effective
solution and something that's really we
design lots of websites for museums and
this sort of way of this simple way of
thinking has actually really kind of
been influencing how i think about
other museum websites as well um
early designs um
when you could sort of keep scanning so
you could
almost like collect artworks and because
the scanner is so
um sensitive in a way and artworks can
be hung close together
the idea was that we wouldn't want to
sort of um you could be confused
actually by accidentally having
having the wrong thing triggered you're
trying to scan one thing but there's
another thing right next to it
and so we thought even while you're sort
of watching one artist talk to you
it might keep scanning and then you sort
of collect up in this tray at the top
and this that's the prototype that we
tested with um
users and we quickly found that that was
confusing and we needed to take this
already simple interface and simplify it
even
even further and remove that feature
a sort of physical
surprise that we saw
was that visitors really want to scan
the label
they're they're so trained to be
scanning like a qr code and also to be
searching for a label
um that uh they would they would walk up
to the label and get really close to it
and scan it and then step back and look
at the and look at the artwork
and the what we were our goal was that
you wouldn't need to be so um
kind of didactic in your use of it but
that it could be a kind of freer
experience of walking around and just
kind of breezing your phone around and
things would pop
up and um we knew from
testing with our visitors that no one
will will read
the instruction that's and that's not a
judgment that's that's for sure i
wouldn't either and you're trying to
like get to it
and get to the get to the experience and
um
so we tried this illustration that could
sort of model the behavior that we were
hoping
for um for visitors to to to take
um even so we it was
so fascinating um walking around with
visitors and talking to them about their
experience using this
um you know and a lot of them talk to us
about their
um you know sort of consciousness of
wanting to look up at the work and not
get too
absorbed in their phone some visitors
just hate it and they absolutely don't
want to use
you know an electronic device when
they're in the museum
[Music]
other you know some kinds of young
people
they just they want to they walk through
they scan absolutely everything they you
know watch the first three seconds of
every video
um and um
and other people um you know it really
had a
transformative experience actually with
it and you know talked about
um you know seeing artists who looked
like them understanding for the first
time
um uh you know that a
contemporary art that might be ugly to
them
um understanding the the motivations of
an artist and where it comes from really
really deep in their connection to it in
a way that
um sometimes they hadn't had before with
this whole
genre of art um
you know this product is used um in real
life and and
i would argue that that's true of of
kind of everything on some level of
everything that um
that was talked about today that um that
there's a physical context in which
people
are you know reading books
or doing data entry or
learning about art or engaging with art
and
that sort of physical disposition was
a big influence on the design of the
interface as well as on solving some of
the kinds of problems that
um that i've just alluded to
so you know early on when we were doing
testing it was important to also sort of
include the labels
and you know think about the context
that this is happening in
this is not a you know a sort of
disembodied
codex of jpegs um
uh for
the sort of fallback so that a user who
tech the image recognition does not work
very well
um on on label text it's not distinct
enough and
so but it was really important that
there be a fallback for someone who
would scan the label we learned that
from from watching visitors and also
because some of these works which i'll
talk about in a minute are
very hard to recognize um and so
in those cases well in every case
basically
there's an image a frame of the video
that you get for example which is more
reliably
which is reliably recognizable and which
also accuse the user
that accused the visitor that this work
is
in the system and one of the nice things
about having such a low barrier to entry
that is not a native application is that
there is this short url that you can
just enter into your web browser at any
time so you can start sort of anywhere
in the system and follow any any pathway
but
basically every work in the museum is in
the system with
i think with a few exceptions at this
point
and finally letting visitors know that
this is here
and that there is this additional
available layer to the experience is
actually sort of one of the biggest
challenges and um
the it's it's even more heightened
actually at the um
at the smithsonian museums on the mall
where um
there's no there's no um there's no pay
gate there's no ticketing so you really
just walk right into the museum so
there's no point at which there's no
inherent point at which
a visitor services staff can say here's
this thing that you can do
so on the one hand there's this low
barrier to entry on the other hand we
really need people to know that they can
take that step
[Music]
the exhibition that we launched with
ironically
was called what absence is made of
and you know an image recognition app
is um about the pixels it's a kind of a
ghost in the shell
um it is about dematerialized objects
so what absence is made of um was a very
poetic exhibition to start with
it featured not exclusively minimalist
and conceptual art but a lot of
a lot of minimalist and conceptual art
just
reading from the description of the
exhibition a curator described it as
the spaces left behind when something
disappears
and as work on a massive scale yet with
the barest materials
and so this is like this is um didier
vermeeran's sculpture and it's kind of
meant
in part to look like the pedestal for
other artwork
um that's fred sandbeck
it's his string that's
raynor novos black squares and these are
joseph boys is this black squares and
it turns out that once you seed even one
black square into your image recognition
database
every dark corner of the museum is now
pops up joseph boyz
and um uh so
uh peter kind of talked about unexpected
i really like seeing that fred wilson um
um uh image and um
talking about unexpected juxtapositions
we really
created a situation in which um uh
the work was sort of work that was meant
to be
curated together and tell a really
amazing story in fact matched up with
each other through this kind of
technological
prism in a way that was
a challenge as well as an opportunity
that's giovanni and selmo this hand is
not part of the artwork the artwork
is um uh is just a single slide and a
slide projector with the word visible
projecting into empty space
and um so you can only see it when you
interrupt the projection
it's also a single slide so it just
slowly burns actually and
under the in the light as it changes it
gets more and more brown every day
so this is a an artwork that is meant to
defy machine vision
um but um uh
you know we can work around those
problems often by um
by seeding the scene and by you know as
a couple of people have talked about by
making sure that we're including humans
in this process of thinking about
um sort of where the artwork
is located literally in this case um and
you know taking a couple steps back
or moving around the sculpture to seed
images that are going to be effective
and that means again watching visitors
and tests doing lots of testing
and you know i think that's a kind of um
kind of like stephen was talking about a
kind of
human knowledge that is always going to
be an essential part of these projects
especially
and will be most effective when you work
um in an interdisciplinary way
so the last image i wanted to show is
sort of the solution to the ensemble
problem and
and you know critic's going to talk
about in a work like that is the artwork
the
projection is it the situation is it the
slide projector
in our case it's the slide projector
that scans actually really effectively
and um uh so here's uh
here's that work kind of shining back
out and this is a team of
of testers from the hirshhorn and the
broader smithsonian
kind of trying to figure this stuff out
um so
we'll stop there thanks a lot
and i just wanted to add that um kind of
going into the next section of the talk
is that um
while the hershey and i was driven with
a very specific content strategy at the
hershon we believe that what we created
is applicable widely across different
subject matter so what we've done at the
smithsonian
is that we've started taking the hershel
knight and adapting it for use
across our different museums and
we're also working with third-party
external organizations and you know
trying to adapt to hershel knight for
their use as well
eventually what we hope to do is to
create a open source version of the
hershel knight
and to make it readily available for
smaller museums and organizations to
pick it up and deploy at their space
as well thank you
[Music]
you